Now that you've seen user input, let's turn to another topic, formatted output.
Let me show you why we need to know about it. Let's look at this program here.
I want to buy 100 cans of my super premium cat food at $4.35 a can. So, my
total price is going to be the quantity times the unit price. So, I'll print
it. There's also 8% tax so, here I'm figuring up the tax, and then I'm printing
that. Let's see what this program does. Well, look at it. It's ugly, ugly.
Here, I expected to see $435, and the tax, you never see tax like that on your
store receipt. It would say $34.80. So that's what I want. And by the way, I
want these decimal points here to line up. It turns out, that's pretty easy to
do. Here, instead of just calling println, we'll call a different method. It's
called printf for print formatted, and here, we need to add a formatting
string. The formatting string is here, it looks a little arcane. The percent
says we're now going to be printing something. The 8 means we want it to be 8
characters wide, the 0.2 means, we went 2 digits after the decimal point. The f
means it's a floating point or decimal number. The \n means, and afterwards,
please give us a new line. As you can see, there's a whole mini language in
these formatting strings and you'll practice a few of them with Sarah, after
I'm done here. But truth be told, if you simply memorize this one. Or even
better just copy and paste it when you need it. That's 90% of what you need.
Let me do just that. So, here again, I'm going to be using a printer. I'm
saying I want field with 8. 2 digits after decimal point. Now, when we run the
program everything is nice and beautiful. Both numbers have two digits after
the decimal point. Both of them occupy eight characters. As a general rule,
whenever you display prices, go ahead and use printf. You'll practice that with
Sara right now.